13 minute workouts 20 minute recipes 10
minute mindfulness ready to become get
feel on the App Store or Google Play
it's Joanna here and today it's going to
be an upper body focused workout so we
want to go back to the basics we want to
perform basic upper body exercises which
will target your back and your chest
your shoulders as well as your arms we
want to do each workout for 40 seconds
with 20 seconds rest okay and that will
be a total of 4 seconds I want you to
focus on proper form and really get the
best out of each workout
let's start with the first workout for
the first workout you need one dumbbell
medium weight dumbbell I would say
between five to six kilos each and the
first workout is going to be single on a
dumbbell row so what I want you to do is
stop one leg back your left leg forward
grab the dumbbell with your right arm
okay just leave slightly forward support
your upper body and I wanted to roll the
dumbbell up and squeeze on your back
okay
so squeeze it up bring it back down slow
and control let's go so up squeeze it
and back down elbow pointed back okay
nice up squeeze and back down so been
from your hips good back down up nice
and control squeeze right at the top and
hold for one count drive the dumbbell
close to your abs and your hips good so
remember do not open your elbow out back
and feel the squeeze on your trapezius
muscles as well good up and back down up
and down good now let's switch and work
on the other side okay so grab the
dumbbell up on your left arm support
your upper body with your right hand
step white and let's just pull it
squeeze and back down I like to work on
single up because this will help to fix
any muscle imbalances so down and up do
not just let the dumbbell drop up nice
and control and squeeze up good open up
your chest and look straight down
remember do not hunch okay you want to
keep your back flat squeeze up and work
on your back muscles good up nice and
control if you want to you can always
challenge yourself and lift more up
and back it down plus two more squeeze
up and down last one more up and jump
very good now grab the other dumbbell
okay risk you using a pair of medium
with dumbbell for the third workout we
want to work on deadlift to show the
press so stems sugar with the pot toast
points a forward bend again from your
hips back down into a dip mix as you
come up drive it up into a shoulder
press ctrl down change it back to the
starting position up and press it
straight up working on your shoulders
and down remember keeping your chest
open and up back up nice and control
back down good slow and controlled back
down turn it over and good so it's a
shoulder press into an upright row and
back into deadlift upright row and show
the press good okay now drop one a
dumbbell we want to repeat all three
exercises again alright so let's start
with your right side left leg forward
right leg back support your upper body
ready and chest up
let's go squeeze it up back down up and
down good squeeze hold for one count and
release feel one side of your back
being work good drive it to your chest
into your core nice straight back down
and up avoid moving your upper body okay
your upper body should remain still and
the movement should only come from your
arms back up down up
and one more and switch let's go now on
the left side okay
support your upper body step back find
your base feel yourself fully grounded
and now left side and let's go up drive
it down up and drive it down good gaze
gently on the floor down up and back it
down
nice and control
good squeeze your back right at the top
elbow pointed back good very good
okay so step wide and you should feel
that your right leg is supporting your
upper body up squeeze it up last one
more up release and good now let's grab
the other dumbbell okay so it's going to
be bit lift to show the press all right
then sugar with a pot toes pointed
forward bending from your hips okay so
keeping your chest open and back flap do
not hunch forward
all right let's go deadlift upright row
straight into shoulder press good and
back down upright row use a little bit
of momentum to help you with the
shoulder presses but not too much down
up press it up working on your shoulders
we want strong and toned showed us up
good back down nice and controlled do
not rush the workout up whoo find your
balance okay kathan your core do your
shoulders working up press up and back
down all right good now let's lie
straight down onto the floor okay we
want to work on chest press
okay so get down onto the mat bring your
heels close to your butt okay lift both
dumbbells up I want it to drive the
dumbbells down elbows in a 90 degree
position push it up and back down nice
and controlled back up good okay
remember that the dumbbells
should be in line with your chest so you
should not go too low or too high up you
should feel the tension on your chest
a little bit on your shoulders to drive
it up if you want to challenge yourself
and work on your glutes you can lift the
butt up into a hip bridge drive the
dumbbells down and up squeezing your
glutes as well back down up and relax
okay
still working on our chest we want to
get into a dumbbell fly okay so instead
of having the dumbbells straight out we
want to have your pumps facing each
other okay and again keep your elbows
bent spread the dumbbells to your side
and lift it back up okay just gently tap
your elbows on the floor and drive it
back up good you should feel the squeeze
on your mid chest whoo right in the
center drop it back down bending your
elbows slightly and squeeze it up
nice again if you want to challenge
yourself you can lift and get into a Kip
bridge position lift it up back down and
up
back down nice and control up slow and
back down
okay now drop the dumbbells we want to
get into push-ups all right hit it I
love it
you've got to do push-ups push-ups is a
great workout to work in a chest as well
as your shoulders plus you will not need
any weights
all right so pumps white let's go on
your toes down and up slow and up good
if this is too tough remember you can
always get on to your knees down and up
and down and up
start somewhere okay as you progress
what you can do is get onto your toes
and challenge yourself nice keep going
only 40 seconds long you have ten
seconds more well it's always a
challenging workout this is up that's
two more up last one more up and rest it
out now let's turn and get back into
chest press
okay so lie on the floor keep your heels
close to your butt get bring both
dumbbells up let's challenge ourselves
and bring our hips off the floor
okay back down push it up
bring it back down and up good and drive
straight up
let's go straight up bring it back down
good doing a good job bring it back down
push it up through your chest
remember your arms should be in a
90-degree position control and back up
if you feel that the dumbbells are
wobbly that's okay your body is still
getting used to the position all right
and now bring both dumbbells with the
pumps facing each other okay as you're
ready bring your hips off of the floor
again and now let's get into dumbbell
fly okay let's go ladies spread your
arms squeeze it up
spread it control fight against
resistance and bring it back up good
slow and nice and squeeze it back up
good keep it slow and up so go for three
counts 1 2 3 and 1 count straight up
good 1 2 3 and 1 count straight up again
1 2 3 squeezing your glutes up let's go
squeeze the glutes do not drop your hips
right now up spread it up and back down
very nice drop the dumbbells your
favorite workout push-ups
all right let's see how many we can do
in 40 seconds ok and after this you will
get a 1 minute rest
all right 3 seconds left give me your
best effort and you will get a 1 minute
rest
let's go down and up
gaze gently on the floor give me your
back flat your neck neutral okay bending
your elbows use your chest muscles to
drive for your body straight up all
right do not take a bath or do not dip
your hips
type in your core good keep going ten
more seconds at least three more last
two more last one more and press it out
okay very good
so we've worked on your back your chest
as well as a little bit on your
shoulders for the next two seconds we
want to focus more on your shoulders as
well as your arms so what I want you to
do is grab a lighter pair of dumbbells
between three to four kilos each okay
keep yourself hydrated wipe your sweat
and we will start in another forty
seconds
[Music]
okay so I would say go for three to four
kilos each if you are completely new to
the workout then you can always start
lighter between one to two kilos each a
day it is very important that you get
the exercise form correct before you
attempt to lift heavier all right okay
you have about 15 seconds left the first
workout is going to be upright row to
run race
so grab your dumbbells pumps facing in
upright row bring the dumbbells to your
chopper chest
bring it back down and run race straight
forward okay so elbows flare it out and
run good
keeping your stance white and firm front
and your core tight so do not do this
okay
if you're swinging your body this is
wrong that you got to lift lighter
okay so bend your knees slightly up back
down tighten your core and front good
strong core strong shoulders good this
workout is really great to work on the
front showed us nice one more upright
row and front rate okay shake it out a
little bit now we want to work on your
side show this okay so grab the
dumbbells with the pumps facing each
other okay what I want to do is lift the
dumbbells to your side arms in a 90
degree position bring it back down and
lift it back up okay you can go wider
than 90 degrees if you want to so up and
back down remember that the dumbbells
should not be higher than your shoulders
okay squeeze the shoulders bring it back
down again type in your car and through
the work on your shoulders
if you're doing this again this is wrong
alright so stand firmly up back down up
suck your belly in back down feel the
work on your side shoulders back down up
down up down and one more whoo sure
that's absolutely burning drop the
dumbbells okay we want to go for punches
all right so what are we to do is step
your left leg forward right leg back and
take this as your recovery work out okay
again strong punches strong straight
left and right punches to work on your
shoulders okay I want you to use the
strength and the power from your hips
and you showed us to drive those punches
do not drop it or do not go too high up
strong twist the hips punch still
working on your shoulders but this is
too active recovery punch forward
punching straight into the screen
together
oh-hoo left right jab cross let's go
spit it up jab cross double jab cross
double jab cross keep going guarding
your face at all times okay do not drop
guard and last one good alright 20
seconds rest we want to repeat the
entire circuit once more so grab your
dumbbells let's start with upright rope
to front race okay so pumps facing in
breathe in breathe out let's work on
your front sure this let's go bring the
dumbbells to your upper chest back down
forward lower it down up okay elbows
point it out good driver elbows point it
to the side and forward very nice
tighten your core keeping your entire
body firm and straight up and down very
nice who do you feel your front
shoulders
they should be burning and back down up
down good keep going whoo
but this workout if you want to you can
also use a barbell all right shake it
off
rest it up we are not stopping right now
we want to go straight into lateral
raise which is to work on your side
showed us okay so pumps facing in stand
with your knees slightly bent and
remember to spread your wings out bring
it back down
spread it out three counts down and
spread it out so don't just let the
weights drop and then drive it up again
control the weights down and drive it
back up back down good up and down
spread your wings very nice oh halfway
there squeeze the flow way you bring the
dumbbells down the more you will work on
your slide show them up and down last
three more up last two more give me one
more okay one more up and done okay drop
the dumbbells active recovery before we
get into our triceps and also biceps
okay
so left leg forward right leg back row
you showed us a little bit keep it loose
skipping nice I want to see a fighting
stance okay so bring your hands both up
let's go jab and cross twist get the
power and momentum from your hips and
work on your shoulders remember the
strength is from your shoulders and your
hips not from your arms okay look
straight ahead keep punching suck your
belly in workout the core muscles at the
same time alright let's give a double
jab punch hook hook double jab punch
hook hook
let's have some fun okay punch hook hook
yeah double jab punch hook hook and now
fast punches whoo let's go keep going
five more seconds
keep working on the shoulders and rest
it out all right next we want to get
straight into triceps and also biceps
okay the first workout is going to be a
combination so grab the dumbbells I want
you to bend from my hips then slightly
forward pumps facing in curl the
dumbbells up bicep curl and straight
into tricep kickbacks okay so curl it up
bicep curl straight into tricep
kickbacks up and back again
with every movement you want to be able
to control the tempo instead of just
rushing through the workout tricep
kickbacks bending from your elbows all
right good
bicep curl straighten it kickback up
curl kickback not few more gaze gently
on the floor good all right shake it a
little bit next it's going to be a
reverse fly this is to work on your
upper back also the high part of your
shoulders alright the back part of your
shoulders so stand again shoot it with a
pad bent from your hips then slightly
forward palms facing Inc spread your
wings to the side control it down spread
it squeeze on the upper back spread and
bring it back down up
back down very good up down up and down
okay
remember do not hunt if you're doing
this this is wrong
straight back chest up spread and
control nice squeeze right at the top
hold it for one count squeeze whole and
back down
whoa one more up and done alright let's
get down onto the floor okay you will
not need your dumbbells for this it's
going to be a four and plank to dolphin
alright so get into a four and plank
what I want to do is get into a full on
plank and Pike your butt up and this
will really work on your shoulders as
well as your arms and your comb all
right good pick it up push it up really
pack your butt up drive your show this
over your elbows and pipe it back up
good so showed us over elbows and
straight up nice remember the more
forward you go the more you will be
working on your arms and your shoulders
down
and straight up and rest it ah alright
okay 20 seconds break we want to get
back up into bicep curl with tricep
kickback okay so grab your dumbbells
let's not stop right now alright again
bending from your hips bicep curl tricep
kickback okay bicep curl tricep kickback
curl it and kick it back good up and
back
this is a really effective strength to
work out to work on your arms to get
them toned and lean up kick it back up
and back nice cut up remember right at
the top you should be filling your
triceps okay squeeze it holy for one can
bring it back down up hold it for one
count and relax okay
next reverse fly alright if you feel
that this weight is too heavy for kilos
is too heavy you can always switch and
grab a light apparent weight
what is important is that you feel the
squeeze on your upper back okay so bend
it from your hips
pumps facing in let's go open it up hold
it and bring it back down squeeze and
control nice and control and back down
good gaze gently on the floor right
keeping your lower body firm up squeeze
Oh push it squeeze and bring it back
down good
spread your elbows out to the side
few more give me two more right one last
one two and let's get down onto the
floor for our final workout all right
four I'm playing - dolphin okay all
right let's get into plank let's hold it
in this position for five seconds before
we start the workout so remember do not
dip your hip do not take it back okay so
go forward Pike your ball straight up
through the stretch forward we're doing
your arms and straight up tighten your
core engage your core straight up
very good elbows your shoulders should
be over your elbows and straight up nice
I can see my sweat dripping on the mat
good keep going
whew last few more strong core strong
upper body
that's one more
I just come down into H house both okay
just stretch out your back and your arms
all right very good
no I just wanted to come up let's just
stretch your upper body out okay so just
bring your shoulders across and just
stretch it out we have done a lot of
work on your shoulders as well as your
arms stretch it out open it to the other
side stretch it out well done guys that
was a really good effort open it and now
let's stretch your triceps okay
aim to bring who your arms straighten
your arms keeping your triceps straight
all right and now on the other side so
straight twist your palm if you can
twist your wrist with the palms facing
out and you should feel a deeper stretch
on your tricep and now just stretch on
your chest as well so what I wait to do
is just give you three big circles okay
and now open up push your chest forward
do the stretch along your chest muscles
and now bring your thumbs put them down
and you should feel the stretch on your
biceps okay
good and I'll just stand up let's go for
three deep breaths okay so breathe in
reach up and give me a really loud side
again again loud breathe in reach up one
two go ah last one breathe in reach up
all right
very very well done that was a total
upper body workout to hit on all major
muscles your back your chest showed us
as well as your arms I would recommend
you to do this workout at least two
times a week and combine it with other
lower body strength training as well as
cardio exercises okay and be sure to
check out more workout videos on my
youtube channel like this video share
this video on and also subscribe to my
youtube channel for a lot more workout
videos fitness tips and recipes see you
next time and remember be sweaty